salut dépêchez-vous le grand pianiste
pierre barbizet est là ecoutez-le
il sait faire parler la musique la
musique ça sert beaucoup à décrire la
peinture aussi ça dépend si vous voulez
la musique elle dépeint par seulement
des paysages mais elle dépend aussi des
sentiments par exemple ça vous et
connaître ça
[Musique]
vous savez
oh
[Musique]
et c'est toujours
comment
ah la la
ajoute la hache en pas très juste un
[Musique]
le
ça fait penser quoi il se réjouit il
fait nuit
il au fond
ses nuits
on
effet ni s'appelle le clair de lune
[Musique]
comment on fait la musique vous
connaissez ça qu'est ce que c'est ça on
est un peu moi aller alors tu vas me
dire le temps qu'il fait
[Musique]
là
et plus ça donne quoi
cette musique
[Musique]
oh
wyplay
il pleut elle a toutes tous lui
s'appelle jardin sous la pluie c'est
debuchy tu vois eh ben il pleut à toutes
et tous qui pleuvaient alors évidemment
c'est un peu triste et ça c'est quoi ça
casimir comme on appelle sa fille gaie
elle t'a dit de l'agent
ça s'appelle comme ça s'appelle j'ai pas
le titre est ce que c'est une soupe le
mois françois je connais un petit peu la
raison ça vous dirait clé des tas de
variation des variations si c'est la
même chose
seulement à des baisses de note oui il
ya une variation il ya trois variations
ou des très très très très visible un
part ça ça ne dépeint pas brillé la
pluie a vécu de lever bon et là alors
vous allez voir c'est pas la pluie c'est
à mai donc j'aime mieux les moments
géniaux les confitures j'aime mieux un
et ma grand mère m'a défendu d'aller
dans le placard où il ya les confitures
alors vous allez voir c'est oui ça c'est
le petit garçon ça
[Musique]
on connaissait le thème non et puis
maintenant il ya la grand-mère série on
s'amuse plus on voudrait bien le croire
sur pc pas redescendue
[Musique]
oh
entends plus suppliant
[Musique]
la grand mère est partie mais on a mangé
trop de confiture
[Musique]
voilà ce que c'est
le
mon
voyez que les variations comme ça
raconte toujours une histoire la musique
un coup d'état de l'histoire ce pas
seulement des paysages le fait qu'il
pleuve ou qu'il fasse soleil ou de la
mer aussi la mer la campagne enfin le
sentiment de la nature un allées
bétonnées
[Musique]
le pétrole
les
c'est la campagne des grands-pères pas
polluer à à l'époque la musique
rodrigues et c'est sacré chemin qui la
rend différente des autres arts
séquelles un quasi mais elle elle
dépeint des sentiments elle dépeint des
joies et des spas des peines des états
d'âme mais des états d'âme et voilà des
des états d'âme